Die Erde ist voller Leben; überall!
Egal, ob extrem heiß oder extrem kalt,
extrem sauer oder extrem basisch; unter
extremem Druck oder in extremer Trockenheit;
hoch in der Atmosphäre und tief in der
Erdkruste. Das Leben findet einen Weg.
…sogar in den Reaktorraum 4 in Tschernobyl.
Da gibt es einen schwarzen Schimmel,
der die für uns tödliche radioaktive
Strahlung einfach als Energiequelle nutzt.
Für die allerersten Lebewesen, wäre sogar dieser
Raum hier* den ich persönlich jetzt gerade ganz
angenehm finde, ein extremer Lebensraum. Denn
damals war die Welt noch eine ganz andere.
Wie in dieser Welt Leben aus toter Materie
entstanden sein könnte, genau darum geht’s jetzt!
Übrigens, falls ihr auch der Meinung
seid, dass es allerhöchste Zeit ist,
etwas für die Rettung unseres Planeten vor
Umweltschäden zu tun, dann bleibt unbedingt
bis zum Ende des Videos dran, da hab ich
eine inspirierende Video-Empfehlung für euch.
Vor 4,2 Milliarden Jahren war die Erde …
steril. Als sie zuvor mit einem marsgroßen
Protoplaneten kollidiert ist, hat die Hitze des
Einschlags die gesamte Erdkruste schmelzen lassen.
Jegliches Wasser war verdampft. Erst schlappe 300
Millionen Jahre später ist es kalt genug geworden,
dass der Wasserdampf kondensieren konnte. Danach
gab es 100 Millionen Jahre deutschen Winter,
aka ununterbrochen Regen. So
sind die Ozeane entstanden.
Und vor 3,7 Milliarden Jahren war in den
Ozeanen auf einmal… Leben! Auf dieses Alter
datiert eine Studie jedenfalls die ältesten
bekannten Lebensspuren. Und wenn man dieser
Studie nicht glauben will, weil sie ein bisschen
umstritten ist, dann sind die ältesten Spuren von
Blaualgen immer noch 3,5 Milliarden Jahre alt.
Und das sind schon relativ komplexe Lebewesen.
Wie konnte auf einem sterilen
Planeten innerhalb von diesen
500 bis 700 Millionen Jahren aus
toter Materie Leben entstehen?
Um die Frage zu beantworten, müssen
wir erst einmal LUCA kennenlernen.
Das ist der hypothetische letzte gemeinsame
Vorfahre aller Lebewesen. Durch genetische
und biochemische Forschung wissen
wir, welche Stoffe die Ur-Mikrobe
LUCA gehabt haben muss und welche
chemischen Reaktionen in ihr abliefen.
Schon seit geraumer Zeit entwickeln
Forschungsteams Hypothesen,
die erklären sollen, wie aus toter Materie
LUCA mit all seinen Bestandteilen geworden
ist. Und die zwei wichtigsten davon
schauen wir uns jetzt mal genauer an.
Das Knifflige dabei eine Hypothese aufzustellen
ist, dass sich alle Bauteile in einem Lebewesen
gegenseitig bedingen. Ohne Erbgut keine Proteine,
ohne Proteine keine Stoffwechselreaktionen,
und ohne Stoffwechsel kein Erbgut … und auch
keine Proteine. Ihr seht wo das hin führt.
Es ist wie beim Radfahren: Zum Losfahren könnte
sich ein Fahrer sich erst aufs Rad gesetzt haben,
oder er hat zuerst das Rad angeschoben, oder
er hat mit einem Tritt ins Pedal begonnen.
Und genauso unterscheiden sich die
Hypothesen über den Beginn des Lebens:
die einen beginnen mit Proteinen, andere mit den
Stoffwechselreaktionen, wieder andere beim Erbgut.
Letzteres ist der Fall bei der RNA-Welt-Hypothese.
Sie besagt, dass vor LUCA quasi halb lebendige
Wesen existierten, die nur aus RNA
bestanden. RNA ist sozusagen die
labile Schwester der DNA. Sie liegt nämlich
nicht als Doppelstrang-Helix vor wie die DNA,
sondern als Einzelstrang. So kann sie viele Formen
annehmen und hat viele freie Bindungsstellen.
Dank ihrer Nukleotidsequenz
kann RNA als Erbmaterial dienen;
wegen der vielseitigen Struktur und mithilfe
der freien Bindungsstellen, aber auch als Enzym,
oder sogar als Gen-Schalter. Theoretisch ist also
eine RNA denkbar, die sich selbst reproduziert
und dabei auch evolviert. Gefunden oder
hergestellt wurde so ein Molekül aber noch nicht.
Als Beweis für die RNA-Welt-Hypothese
wird angeführt, dass RNA an zentralen
Reaktionen des Lebens beteiligt ist. Vor allem bei
der Replikation der DNA und bei
der Protein-Biosynthese. Und,
nein, das heißt nicht, dass messenger
RNA-Impfstoffe dein Erbgut verändern.
Wie die RNA aber ursprünglich entstanden sein
soll, daran scheiden sich nach wie vor die
Forschergeister. Verschiedene Reaktionswege
sind denkbar, aber wenn man sie in der
Natur ablaufen lassen will, erfordern sie
teilweise recht komplizierte Umgebungen,
die mal feucht und mal trocken sind… das
scheint alles noch sehr wackelig und spekulativ.
Dieses Problem versucht dagegen die
Hydrothermalquellen-Hypothese gleich als Erstes
zu lösen. Hydrothermalquellen sind heiße Schlote
am Meeresgrund. Sie entstehen dort, wo Magma
relativ nah an den Meeresboden herankommt und
Meerwasser tief in das Erdgestein sickern kann.
Das Wasser wird erhitzt und reagiert
dann mit den Mineralien im Gestein,
wodurch einige nützliche Verbindungen
entstehen; insbesondere molekularer
Wasserstoff, der eine zentrale Rolle bei
der Energiegewinnung in Zellen spielt.
Ein Forschungsteam fand heraus, dass
LUCA etwa 400 Stoffwechselreaktionen
gehabt haben muss. Das ist nicht
besonders viel, bedeutet aber,
dass sie schon vor LUCA dagewesen sein müssen.
Fast alle dieser 400 Reaktionen – nämlich
97% – könnten theoretisch in Hydrothermalquellen
von alleine ablaufen. Für eine dieser Reaktionen,
die Pyruvat-Synthese, wurde das im Laborversuch
bereits nachgewiesen. Das Erstaunliche dabei:
Lebewesen benötigen viele Reaktionsschritte, um
Pyruvat herzustellen. Unter den Bedingungen in
der Hydrothermalquelle ging das in nur einem
Schritt! Hydrothermalquellen sind also quasi
ein Shortcut für Leben: Sie machen das möglich,
wofür Lebewesen sonst viele Enzyme bräuchten.
Die Poren im Gestein der Hydrothermalquellen
wären also perfekte Reaktionsräume,
aus denen die entstehenden Stoffe nicht
entkommen können. Sie bleiben eng zusammen
und so können die Stoffwechselreaktionen weiter
ablaufen. Das ist in lebenden Zellen ja auch so.
Offene Fragen gibt es bei dieser Hypothese
aber natürlich auch noch. Zum Beispiel,
wie sich diese Systeme in Membranen
einkapseln und ein Erbgut entwickeln konnten.
Aber die Hydrothermalquellen-Hypothese eröffnet
uns die Möglichkeit, neu darüber nachzudenken,
wo Leben wahrscheinlicher ist als anderswo. Sogar
in unserem eigenen Sonnensystem! Zum
Beispiel auf einem Mond des Saturn.
Unsere Erde umkreist die Sonne in
einer Entfernung, die flüssiges
Wasser auf der Oberfläche erlaubt. Und
weil alle Hypothesen zur Entstehung
des Lebens flüssiges Wasser voraussetzen,
bezeichnet man diese Zone als “bewohnbar”.
Neben Sternenlicht gibt es aber noch andere
Energiequellen, die Wasser flüssig halten
können. Der Mond Enceladus wird zum Beispiel
durch Gezeitenkräfte von innen aufgewärmt.
An einem seiner Pole schießt Wasser aus
seiner mehrere kilometerdicken Eiskruste.
Der Grund könnte ein riesiger Ozean sein, der
unter der Eisdecke den ganzen Mond umspannt.
Die Cassini-Mission hat Proben von
dem Wasser analysiert, das da aus
der Oberfläche schießt. Das Ergebnis lässt
auf Hydrothermalquellen schließen! Und wenn
man der Hydrothermalquellen-Hypothese folgt,
heißt das, dass dort Leben entstehen könnte;
außerhalb der bewohnbaren Zone
und sogar ganz ohne Licht!
Auch der Jupiter-Mond Europa könnte
einen Ozean aus flüssigem Wasser mit
Hydrothermalquellen beherbergen. Deshalb
bereitet man sich bei der NASA darauf vor,
Sonden zu den beiden Eismonden zu schicken,
um dort nach Leben zu suchen. Und auch auf
dem Mars könnte vor langer Zeit Leben
in Hydrothermalquellen entstanden sein.
Wasser und Eisenmineralien gibt es dort ja
und Perseverance sucht fleißig nach Spuren.
Aber was ist mit den Planeten, zu
denen wir keine Sonden schicken können?
Auch da können wir vom Leben auf der Erde lernen.
Das Leben hat die Erde nämlich schon ziemlich früh
ziemlich stark verändert. Als die Blaualgen die
Photosynthese erfanden, produzierten
sie Unmengen an Sauerstoff. So viel,
dass erst alles oxidiert wurde, was
oxidiert werden konnte. Und dann auch
noch die Atmosphäre mit Sauerstoff
angereichert wurde. Heute besteht
die Luft zu über 20% aus Sauerstoff. Ohne
das Leben wäre da gar kein Sauerstoff!
Wenn es in der Atmosphäre eines fremden Planeten
also einen Stoff gibt, der dort eigentlich nicht
von selbst entstehen kann, dann hat man
vielleicht potentiell möglicherweise einen
Biomarker, also ein Anzeichen für Leben
entdeckt! Und die Atmosphäre von Planeten
können wir mit Hilfe des Lichtspektrums
untersuchen, das uns von dort erreicht.
Ihr habt vielleicht gehört, dass ein
Forscherteam auf diese Weise in der
Atmosphäre der Venus Phosphin entdeckt haben
will. Einige Forscherinnen und Forscher glauben,
dass Phosphin auf der Venus ein Biomarker sein
könnte, andere sind sich da nicht so sicher. Bei
einer Entdeckung solcher Tragweite sollte man
aber natürlich auch möglichst skeptisch sein;
außergewöhnliche Behauptungen benötigen
außergewöhnlich gute Beweise. Trotzdem wird schon
spekuliert, wie Leben in den oberen Schichten
der venusianischen Atmosphäre aussehen könnte.
Ich finde es super spannend darüber
zu spekulieren, wie das Leben auf der
Erde entstanden sein könnte. Aber es wird
wahrscheinlich auch immer eine Spekulation
bleiben. Wir können ja leider nicht 4 Milliarden
Jahre in die Vergangenheit reisen. Ziemlich sicher
ist wohl, dass das Leben für seine Entstehung
einen felsigen Himmelskörper mit flüssigem
Wasser und eine Energiequelle benötigt. Und die
Hydrothermalquellen-Hypothese zeigt uns, dass die
Energie nicht von der Sonne kommen muss. So kommen
neue Orte für die Entstehung von Leben in Frage.
Sollten die Expeditionen zu
Enceladus und Europa Leben finden,
wäre das vielleicht die Bestätigung der
Hydrothermalquellen-Hypothese… und eine
Sensation, die die Weltsicht vieler
Menschen auf den Kopf stellen dürfte.
Jetzt kommt die inspirierende
Video-Empfehlung für all diejenigen,
denen der Schutz unseres Planeten
genauso am Herzen liegt wie mir:
Die Rewilding-Organisation Planet Wild
veröffentlicht jeden Monat ein neues Video,
um unseren Planeten zu renaturieren und
die Schäden zu beheben, die die Menschen
der Natur zufügen. Und das alles wird von einer
Community finanziert, der jeder beitreten kann,
der unserem Planeten helfen möchte, sich zu
erholen. Ich selbst bin Teil davon, weil ich
es unglaublich gut und wichtig finde, etwas
zu unternehmen und nicht nur darüber zu reden.
In diesem Video verwandeln sie einen riesigen,
sterbenden Wald in ein klimaresistentes
Ökosystem und in diesem hier retten sie den
süßesten Vogel Europas vor dem Aussterben.
Die Planet Wild-Videos sind wirklich einzigartig.
Es geht sowohl um effektiven Umweltschutz,
als auch um spannendes Hintergrundwissen
und Unterhaltung. Sehr coole Kombi.
Also: Schaut Euch jetzt unbedingt die
Planet Wild-Videos an [zeigt auf End Cards]
Und bleibt neugierig, Euer Cedric